[Music]
hello Iran I'm sorry no malesko I'm an
engineer in the developer relations team
hi I am C I'm a sinner I am engineer in
UI toolkit team hi - hey kono naka I was
an engineer in UI toolkit team last year
we told you the basics of best practices
with text and this year we want to build
on top of that so if you haven't seen
that talk yet go check it out well wait
this year we looked again at we looked
again at topics that you have most
problems with the ones that you feel are
most challenging so in this look we're
gonna cover a variety of topics some are
wider more generally applicable and some
are more niche advanced topics and the
solutions as you'll see are either new
API sin cube or some specific guidance
so let's get started okay let's get
started from performance the performance
is a top topic in the user experience
and text is one of the most heavily used
component in UI toolkit team this part
from the usage the most of the internal
things are Brad box and hard to optimize
for many of the purpose
we have been keep improving the text
view performance and show some useful
tips in the skill goryeo this year first
let me announce that the hyphenation
is now turned off by default in under
the queue and up combat version 1.1 as
we talked the last year the hyphenation
has a huge impact to the text view
performance actually the 70% of the
tick's work is for - asians so we turned
off it by default if you need - asians
please monitoring it
in application to enable the - Asians
preset - Asian frequency attribute to
normal in style XML or late XML
also you can call set - Asian frequency
method in your code okay next we list
the precomputed text in last bill gray
oh this is a truth for doing text work
in background set this does 90% of text
work beforehand selecting phones or a
measuring text this is a food-safe
object and should be created in
background set and we bought ported this
crust to jet pack and available from API
21 then this year we added new utt ApS
for easy integration with recyclable
prefix before routing into the details
let's see the overview of the recyclable
profits this figure shows the workload
of us read and render thread us said
that some work and pass the rendering
work to render thread the eye icon shows
the timing of be sync this figure shows
a good state nothing broke the missing
event but if some day work takes time
and couldn't finish until the next
billing event it end up with a dual
exams in this example the late works
takes time and blocks and XP sync event
this typically happens when the new item
is appeared by scrolling the idea of
Triffids is doing this new item process
in much earlier time when the user set
is idle if everything goes well the
workload of the user should have this
mute it and we can prevent you a junk
this is just an overview so if you need
more details please exit articles on the
under developer medium publication this
is how prefetch works but this prefix
has two limitations
the prefix still works on the us-led
Express takes longer time that creates
still blocks the vsync event this
typically happens when you set long long
text to text view one obvious solution
for this problem is moving some work to
background set actually you can move
some text to work to background set by
using my computer text however in
general moving some work to background
set is not a trivial work so we
introduce new utt api's for make this
happen easily the API is get text future
in pretty Computex compact and fit text
future in up combat experience let's see
how it works when you write application
is recyclable you may say text in owned
by the beholder core back like this then
if we move is a fixed work to background
set the code looks like this let's see
it I my name first
let's call get text future the get ex
future schedule takes work on the past
executor and returns the future of the
result once you get the future you can
set it to the up convert text view by
calling set text future basically that's
it by calling the digital a P is you can
move the text work to background slate
this is pretty simple but please note
that you cannot change the stairs after
calling get text future because get
dicks future scheduler text work with
the parameters when it is called so if
you change the start after that the
async work wizard won't match up with
the parameters of the textview then its
end up with the exception so if you want
to change the stairs please do it be ho
: get this future if you need more
details or what what is under the fruit
please fix the article on under the
developer medium publication thank you
far apart from performance another thing
that everyone needs to work with is text
styling but with so many ways of styling
text which one should you use and what's
the president's order for each of them
so one of the easiest way to style text
is by just using the text view
attributes but the problem with this is
that this is tedious and error-prone if
you for example need to update the color
of the text views you need to see
absolutely every text via your
application and then do that update the
solution for this is working with stats
they bring you consistency reusability
and easy updates and this actually
bringing us for the first president's
order so you see here we have both the
text size in the style and also in the
text attribute so which textile would
which text size well the text actually
has well the view attributes overrides
the one from the style so what you'll
see here is a text that's 16s be a views
have a default style so for example for
the button that's a subclass of the text
view you'll see that we're also using a
theme attribute that's the button style
well in material theme this point
YouTube's a certain style which spells
different elements including attributes
of the text of the bottom by setting
your default styles it means that
styling becomes an opt-out rather than
opting by default all buttons
independent if you're adding them to new
screens or your refactoring will have a
default style so you'll only not need to
modify them if you specifically want to
change the style for the button so by
default but this default style is going
to be overridden by any style that sets
directly on the via the bottom
properties
some Eagle I might have seen here are
set using the text appearance so text
appearance actually functions very
similarly to a style under the hood that
takes we checks whether the view has a
text appearance it loads it it applies
it to the view and then it has all the
other attributes like the text style
also so this means that as a personal
sorter the text appearance is then
overridden by the default style and then
the style and then the few attributes
but there's something you should know
about text appearance it's
character-building it only supports
character level styling it doesn't
support paragraph a level styling like
line Heights or break strategy these can
be customized here in Android q we added
a new attribute in text appearance the
phone variation settings and the same
attribute starting from Q can be used in
text view and in app compat text view
some of the text appearance attributes
are also supported in text appearance
span before Q the text appearance pan
didn't read some of the text attributes
like ty face or shadow so starting from
Q the text experience pan is updated to
read and apply these attributes as well
also nearing Q speaking of spans we've
added implementations to two news fans
line height span and line background
span when applying a span on top of text
styling keep in mind that the properties
of the span said the properties that are
set by the span will override any other
properties that you might be setting the
IEP style or default style or you but
what if you want to change some
attributes of the text view at the app
level so let's say that you want to
change the entire font in your
application well for this you would use
themes so for example here we're setting
the font family attribute to set the
theme
the theme is part of the view styling
system and it overrides anything that's
applied in the text appearance but it
will override any more specific
attributes so for the text styling we
looked at the president's order to help
you better understand why or why not
style is applied thanks hi again thank
you so we have cover tips related to
text styling and also performance and we
will continue with phones which is an
important part of text styling and also
your applications brand identity over
the years you have mentioned us about
the shortcomings of phone support on
Android and in the last five years we
have added features such as downloadable
forms and phones in examined this year
we have improved the typeface and font
related LPS based on the further
feedback we got let's go over a real
life in use case and let's assume that
we have an app and in one of our buttons
we want to use an icon in between the
text and we want this icon to be
rendered using the icon font and for the
remaining of the text we want to use
another custom font let's say lotto
when we want to do this we are kind of
in trouble because the button will
accept only a single type face and the
typeface can be created using a single
font or font family actually in the
current API we can use a typeface span
give the icon phone into it and cover
the icon character and then for the
whole body and we can choose to use the
lotto phone however things will get much
more complicated if we were to try to
support multiple languages with their
own custom phones using spans here is
definitely not a scalable solution
because you will have a lot of languages
to support and it's pretty hard to
accurately identify different languages
for a given string and on top of that
you know over the years I have heard
continuously
emoji for example is pretty hard and if
you have another custom emoji phone that
would yet pay there for an Android queue
we added custom fallback builder to the
typeface class it enables you to create
a typeface using multiple phones or font
families when we check our multi
language use case here we create a
builder and for each of the languages we
create a font family and add the related
forms into them and this will also show
the icon phone to use case as well where
this time again we put the icon font as
a separate form family into the final
typeface then you have multiple styles
for a font family you can add them into
the same font family object and whenever
you set the text we have to use bold
style or mark a portion of the text to
be both using spans the system will
choose the correct bold font from the
given configuration then creating a
typeface using this builder you can add
up to 64 font families however what you
cannot do is you cannot put the phones
that belong conceptually to a different
font families into the same font family
object the reason is the system expects
the fonts that are in the same font
family to have to have the same code
coverage which means that they have to
have one-to-one mapping between the
characters that they support and the
other thing that you cannot do is to put
two of the same style phones into the
same font family for example here if I
were to put lotto ball twice into the
font family same font family I will get
an exception and when you define a
custom fallback window he does have the
system works it does a scan shell search
over the string and also over the phones
that are provided for example in here it
will start with the Japanese character
and it will check if lotto font supports
this character if not it will go to the
second one
Seco segi and at that point it will try
to cover as many characters as possible
using the same phone and then it will do
that
same thing over again and if the string
contains language that is not supported
with the given font the system will use
the system fall back use case which is
the current case for Android and
typeface as a control over system fall
back the Navy ApS has a function named
set system fall back where you define
what kind of generic family should be
preferred while choosing a font from the
system fall back since Lotto is a
sans-serif font here I tell the system
that if a character is not supported by
lot or the font that I added
I want system to prefer a SAN serif font
just like the current typeface builders
you can set while creating a font you
can set the weight slant and also the
variable font settings on a font object
and finally in terms of font matching
let's assume that you added two
different way that forms into the same
font family 400 and 700 and by using
text font weight on text we've text from
8 attribute on textview requested to
render this text using a 600 font in
such mismatches the system will use the
closest match or style for this case it
will choose to use 700 text font rate
was recently added I think in p2 text
field and it's also currently being read
by text appearance span the summit
[Applause]
as he explained we expanded the font
experience in under the queue for job
applications on the other hand there's
another strong demand from NDK
application developers about system
fonts so we decided to add new api's for
existing system fonts from native code
this would be a great tools for indica
application filters tickets on the
screen like a games document viewer or
browsers first what is a system font
under the supports over 100 languages
and each languages may require different
font files for example to draw Hindi you
may need the blogger font in case of
pixel 3 to support this large number of
languages it has over 270 font files are
installed to draw text NDK application
like document viewer needs to know which
system font can render a given text this
is not a trivial question so we added
two new API for this the API is font
mature API this is the interface of the
system internal construction engine this
font section
engine is also used by the text view so
you can get the same result as in the
text view okay let's see how to how this
works let's think with this example the
core API is a font much-much function
this takes a search string and output to
acute returns to output font and length
please note that this API is simple for
it for explaining these behaviors the
real API is written in C and takes more
parameters anyway
this function would return in this
example font notice and she jokela gear
and length three need that this length
three means first three chapters can be
rendered with the return font in this
case not all sounds gjk okay now we
notice two points for the first
characters first three characters what
about remainings since we know the first
three characters let's advance the
search range in this case moving
starting off just by three then for the
same function game on the second time
this API returns font
lovato legger and length eight again
this eight means the next eight
characters in this example it's
increased of whitespace can render the
logo to regular font then advanced
search range then call function again on
the third time now we'll each is the end
of the string so we get all funds for
the given characters as you seen it by
keep coding these functions you can get
font files for all characters this is
how this API works but please note that
this API never returns new pointers even
if no function renders given font this
API still returns a byte font object
this front of that should be used for
drawing missing weak symbol called tofu
similarly even threaten no font exactly
matches with the given parameters this
font dysfunction still returns the font
which should have a crosses style
okay this is font matching API this API
gives an answer to the question what
font should be used for the text on the
other hand just another frequently asked
questions what fonts are installed in
the device to answer these questions we
also add a new API code font in a
million API this font intimacy API gives
user access to the system install the
font files let's see how to use this the
Java API is very simple you can just
call system fonts get the available
forms this gives you a set of system
install font files and you can get a
crew pass of the system forms in case of
and decay it starts from creating a
traitor object by keep coding isolated
next function to a later you can access
all system installer font files but
please note that the returning order
doesn't mean anything here for example
even in front a comes before phone to be
that doesn't mean found a has higher
priority than front B this next function
returns in random order
finally there's another knot here this
fontina mercy API is not so fast so we
recommend you to cast the result since
the system front system font
configuration is read-only and modified
only by the system update so you can
give the result for a longer time until
the next system update thank you
[Applause]
one of the most used subclasses of text
view is edit text and pretty much
everything that applies to the text view
also applies to edit text but on top of
this there are some other things that
you need to handle things like layout
styling keyboard configuration input
formatting internationalization and more
unfortunately we don't have time to go
over all of these today but we will
cover some of them so first of all when
working with edit text you actually
interact with three different processes
the first one is your application the
next one is the soft keyboard named
input method service and then the third
one is the system process that
orchestrates loves to and because this
is an inter process communication you
might see in some cases a slight delay
between key events entered in the UI and
then showing up in the app so visually
any text has the following components
the hints the text the background the
selection the cursor and the cursor and
selection handles the background cursor
and handles the colors for these are
updated when you set the color secondary
in your application theme they're
actually just drawables that use color
control normal and color control
activated in their definitions so
actually you can also modify those seem
overlay attributes to change their color
each of these robles themselves can also
be updated using related attributes but
probably the one you want to set the
most is edit text background finally
text color hint edit text color and text
highlight color are also used to update
the color of the other three apart from
these attributes just like text view
edit text has its own default style
which is the edit text file attributes
and this can report it to your own
custom style so use this attribute to
change any edit text view attributes
such as text size or text file
as you all know edittext has support for
compound troubles and sometimes we see
those compound robos are being used as
action buttons on the edit text such as
a clear action however using the robos
as buttons comes with a lot of
constraints and it definitely negatively
impacts the final user experience things
like when you add an action button you
will probably want to show the ripples
on touch maybe animate the icons have
more than one icon on each side and then
you will also have the accessibility
requirements all of these features are
already supported by the existing Riven
layout system and therefore we would
suggest to use them instead
apart from being convenient at first I
believe that there might be two reasons
why people would like to choose to go
that way and use it the robust one of
them is having the same edit text look
and feel over the whole group and the
other one is being able to contract and
expand the editable area based on the
visibility of the button you should
definitely use text input layout and
that will cover a lot of use cases
however if you have application specific
requirements that are not supported by
text input there you should create your
own view group and layout and in order
to address the issue of having the same
look and feel you can set the edit text
background to now and use the exact same
background that is already in the system
for the view group the only thing we
have to do is in order to respond to the
state changes for the drawable such as
pressed and focused you have to add the
add States from children attribute to
the parent layout
another common issue in terms of edit
text that we are aware of is how the
keyboard plays with a possible input
validation error depending on the
location of the input field the error
can remain behind the keyboard and you
really want to see the users to be able
to see what went wrong let's say when
they were going to going to the
sign-up process this is currently the
case also for the text input layer and
there is an open ticket about it but
until we get to address this issue in
the material library here is how what we
can be in order to make those errors
visible there is already a system in
place that keeps the editable area
visible after the keyboard shows up and
all we want to do is to tell the system
instead of the edit text area which is
the green box in here use the yellow box
and in order to do that we have to
extend from edit text and overwrite
three functions I have added a sample
code to the URL given in the slide but I
will go through the functions briefly
get focused rectangle is used to find
the next focusable widget returns a
rectangle or updates a rectangle get
global visible rectangle defines the
visible array of a view and finally the
first rectangle on screen is used by
edit text to request from the system to
make a certain area visible in terms of
the edit text where the cursor is get
focused rectangle implementation is
pretty straightforward and simple you
let the edit text to fill in the
rectangle and you just update the bottom
of the final rectangle to be the parents
body and you do the same thing for the
global visible rectangle finally for
request rectangle on screen again we let
the edit text to request its own
rectangle and then we request another
rectangle which is at the bottom of our
parent layout the number 10 here is just
a magic number to define a rectangle at
the bottom of the parent going back to
the edit text configuration and how it
works with keyboard as you all know when
you set the input type attribute to text
password their characters on the screen
will be invisible however this
information is also being shaped to the
keyboard in order to change its behavior
now the keyboard itself is a turtle or
is a another application that can be
installed from Playstore
therefore they can define their own
behavior based on the signals they get
since we cannot rely on their behavior
we still have to validate the input on
our side however being able to using the
correct input types and IME options is
important to reduce the friction for the
ant user as much as possible and when
you set the input type the number
password use you have a visible change
on the keyboard where they show the
number pad if you have a custom
component let's say and you toggle the
visibility of the password you still
want to signal the keyboard that this is
a password field and they should not
learn about what the user types because
you don't want the keyboard itself which
is not under your control to show back
the user here is your password I know
about it because it gets a little creepy
for the users and the cases where you
don't want the keyboard to learn is not
limited to the password fields things
like an incognito mode such as in Chrome
or a promo code in your checkout screen
really thinks that you don't want the
keyboard to learn about for those cases
you can set the or you can add the non
personalized learning flag to the IME
options one more IME option that is
important in my opinion is flag force
ASCII a lot of times we have seen that
developers are expecting when they set
the password when they set the input
type to text password they expect the
keyboard to show an ASCII keyboard
however text password is definitely not
a strong signal for them to see which to
ASCII keyboard so if you have an ASCII
on the field such as user name and
password maybe you might want to add
this flag to ome options one last case
that can happen for applications is the
control over the application language
text with language and the keyboard
language if you are an application such
as a learning application
learning application or a translation
application there might be a case where
the main language of the application is
different than the language of the edit
text which can be different than the
language of the keyboard because the
user can set any language that they want
if you want to a signal to keyboard to
use a specific language and switch to
that language you can use set IME hint
locales function on the edit text since
we mentioned that keyboard behavior
depends on the keyboard implementation
and they can define their own behavior
there might be times where you might
want to learn about which keyboard is
active at any given time you can read
the active keyboard from the settings
and this will give you the class name
and the package name of the keyboard we
covered so many fantastic things with
text in this talk but let's see what are
some of the key things we should
remember first in terms of performance
keep in mind that the hyphenation is now
turned off by default in android q and
app compat 1.1 so if you need it enable
it and also you should use pre computed
text with recyclerview prefetch for text
styling keep in mind the precedence
order if you're trying to style
something and you don't see the result
it's likely been overridden by something
with a higher precedence if you need to
support multiple phones in your app use
the custom fallback builder API to find
the font used by the system use the font
matter API and then to find all the
installed fonts use the font enumeration
API in terms of edit text use the
symmetry buttes and the Android text
edit text style to style your edit texts
make sure you don't use the edit text
robles as actions so you can enable
instant extensibility and
maintainability and also use ime flags
to configure soft keyboard for a better
user experience so these were some top
tips to make
your text terrific thank you
[Music]